[Música]
uma vez a gente estava fazendo um
encontro para discutir a educação ea
gente quis fazer uma apresentação das
pessoas presentes de uma forma diferente
inusitada e aí a gente criou uma
abordagem que a gente achou inicialmente
supergene ao que era as pessoas se
apresentar em enquanto um palito de
fósforo tivesse acesas nas mãos delas
[Música]
e aí a gente começou a experimentar isso
as pessoas foram se apresentando e logo
logo a gente começou a perceber que a
nossa abordagem não era tão genial assim
e os palitos começaram a se apagar muito
rápido fazer uma demonstração aqui
espero não colocar fogo no auditório
[Música]
hoje cinco segundos esse é o tempo que a
nossa abordagem genial permite às
pessoas falarem se introduzirem naquele
espaço que a gente estava criando e em
determinado momento surgiu uma pessoa a
gabi uma grande amiga minha
quando ela foi falar ela sacou seu
palito começou a se introduzir se
apresentar e logo logo paulista pagou
igual esse aqui que eu acabei de acender
ela sacou palito reserva porque a gente
tinha também um palito reserva
o palito reserva também se apaga o
rapidão e aí ela muito astuta ela
desafiou o sistema
ela disse pra gente gente eu vou
terminar de me apresentar e ela
simplesmente terminou e falou tudo que
ela precisava falar naquele momento e
depois isso gerou um clima na sala um
climão né
a gente ficou só olhando a gente teve
espaço até para conversar sobre isso a
gente abriu uma reflexão coletiva ali ea
gente percebeu que esse sistema do
palito que foi imposto por nós
ele dizia muito sobre o sistema
educacional que a gente queria combater
ele não dava voz para as pessoas e aí a
gente começou a fazer essa pergunta é
possível uma educação que não apague a
nossa chama interna
a minha busca tem sido há cinco seis
sete anos
conscientemente responder essa pergunta
e eu comecei em 2014
eu fiz um financiamento coletivo catarse
foi o início do projeto que chamou
educação fora da caixa
e aí eu começava o que eu chamei outras
pessoas estão chamando de doutorado
informal
eu quase fui parar na pós graduação
tradicional minha formação em
administração pública não é educação
mas eu queria muito estudar esse tema e
eu não teria necessariamente voltar para
as instituições tradicionais e é um
grande amigo meu andré gravatá que é um
ativista da educação de são paulo
ele criou esse nome porque ele também
tinha essa mesma vontade de investigar
uma coisa que
gostava muito mas sem necessariamente se
render às imposições do sistema
acadêmico e ele falou que as pessoas que
ele estava fazendo um doutorado informal
em poesia e aí quando eu soube dessa
ideia eu fiquei absolutamente encantado
com essa possibilidade
e aí eu fiz um financiamento coletivo
pra viabilizar a escrita de um livro que
depois veio a ser o doutorado informal
o livro a gente começou dentro desse
processo da escrita do livro a delinear
alguns princípios algumas diretrizes do
que a gente entendia ser a base do
doutorado informal
a gente queria saber do que a gente
estava falando porque doutorado informal
podia ser absolutamente qualquer coisa a
gente queria dar uma base mas sem
engessar a gente queria criar um
movimento
o primeiro princípio é a curiosidade
eu gosto de pensar a curiosidade como um
fio que a gente puxa de um novelo ea
gente vai puxando puxando puxando e ele
vai cada vez nos apresentando coisas
absolutamente maravilhosas coisas que
nos encantam
eu não sei se já tiveram a experiência
de quando vocês estão muito encantados
fascinados com um tema vocês começam a
pesquisar no google sobre aquilo que
vocês não conseguem parar de acessar a
página após página um link demanda para
o outro que te manda pro outro e te
manda pro outro
isso é a curiosidade em ação e ela gera
série de piedade que é essa descoberta
aparentemente por acaso mas que na
verdade não é na verdade é a gente se
colocando em movimento para acessar o
que é valioso para nós
o segundo princípio é autonomia
eu gosto muito de pensar a autonomia
como uma espécie de musculatura que a
gente precisa treinar para que a gente
chegue cada vez mais perto de quem a
gente é que o sistema tradicional de
educação e mestre em teoria nossa
autonomia e nesse sentido a gente diz
muito movimento e doutorado informal que
a gente quer com as nossas pesquisas
negar a forma mas também da forma a
forma é o que vem pré estabelecido
empacotado pela sociedade e que nem
sempre representa o que a gente é e as
formas são as nossas maneiras de se
expressar no mundo
o terceiro princípio a gente chamou de
percurso e é muito interessante a gente
perceber que na educação tradicional a
gente vê o sistema formal
a gente só conhece curso não tem curso
de graduação cursos de doutorado curso
de fotografia curso de administração
o que muda quando a gente acrescenta
essa outra palavrinha se prefixo pé
a gente cria um percurso quando foi
investigar a raiz etimológica da palavra
percurso
eu percebi que ter é um prefixo latino
que quer dizer integralidade percorrer
percurso tem a ver com o caminhar
integralmente fazer o caminho completo
isso me fez uma reflexão de que percurso
é agente integrar todas as dimensões da
aprendizagem dentro da gente quando a
gente se dispõe a criar um camisa 10
quando a gente fala de educação
tradicional geralmente a gente está
muito aqui no cabeção mental e o
percurso pra mim é o convite do
doutorado informal é agente acessar as
outras dimensões
é a gente aprender com a cabeça com o
coração com as mãos e com a alma um
percurso ele naturalmente vai gerar
entregas é muito como se a gente tivesse
alimentando um copo preenchendo ele de
todo o conhecimento que a gente está
construindo a partir do que interessa
gente e uma hora esse copo vai enchendo
ele transborda também não sei se vocês
já tiveram essa
essa experiência mas quando a gente está
muito engajado numa investigação no
processo de criação de aprendizagem é
natural que a gente queira falar para as
pessoas sobre isso
a gente fica encantado o pessoal do
tédio só fala sobre o tédio de inteiro e
isso é maravilhoso porque isso gera
entrega a entrega ea gente comunicando o
que a gente conhecer o que a gente
aprendeu para o mundo
é importante a gente entregar relevância
para o mundo e essas relevância dessas
importâncias podem assumir qualquer
formato que a gente quiser não precisa
ser necessariamente uma tese uma
dissertação que muitas vezes vai ficar
presa na biblioteca da faculdade ninguém
nunca vai ver
por fim sabedoria a sabedoria um convite
constante para que a gente pense a que
serve o conhecimento que estou
produzindo agora isso que eu estou
aprendendo estou comunicando para o
mundo serve a vida serve as pessoas
serve o planeta
quando a gente junta estes quatro e
cinco princípios da capa mas não é a cap
que vocês alguns de vocês já conhecem a
capps do governo federal aquela agência
que enche o saco e dos povos do anos é a
capa do doutorado informal e é um
convite para que a gente se manifesta em
cinco princípios do nosso processo de
aprendizagem
quando eu estava investigando sobre isso
e criando esses princípios
eu fiquei muito feliz de saber que
vários outros projetos ao redor do mundo
já estão também fazendo essa mesma
lógica é o caso por exemplo do open
masters que é um projeto nos estados
unidos
o pai mestre uma tradução livre seria
mestrado aberto que tem né pelo nome até
uma semelhança incrível com doutorado
informal surgiu na mesma época e ele
propõe a formação de comunidades de
aprendizado intencionais para pessoas
que querem investigar um tema fazer o
seu mestrado livre aberto
tem também o self que é um projeto na
inglaterra em londres que trabalha com
uma ideia genial de maratona de
aprendizado
eles gostam de dizer que aprender como
correr uma maratona e tem a dor ea
delícia disso
por um lado tem aquele prazer do
exercício todo maratonista é quem está
aqui que corre maratonas sabe o quanto é
maravilhoso mas também tem a resiliência
tem a resistência de permanecer
treinando e se esforçando a mesma coisa
com o aprendizado
eu fui pesquisando mais e mais sobre
isso sobre como que as pessoas aprendem
como que eu mesmo aprendi a nesse
processo de escrever os livros eu
cheguei numa palavra que ficou cada vez
mais importante nessa palavra é
comunidade comunidade é quando a gente
vive história junto é quando a gente se
emociona junto eu podia perguntar aqui
pra vocês é quais que seriam as
histórias mais impactantes quais são as
lembranças mais gostosas que vocês
tiveram quando você estava na escola ou
na universidade
já fiz essa pergunta pra muita gente
em 90% na maioria das vezes as pessoas
respondem os amigos que eu conquistei lá
foram os vínculos que eu criei
fortalecer as histórias que eu vivi isso
a comunidade
então eu comecei a me perguntar como é
que a gente faz capps essa capa em
comunidade como que a gente permite às
pessoas aprenderem livremente em
comunidade
isso é o que eu tô trabalhando no
momento
eu cheguei numa idéia que eu batizei de
como viabilizar a ação viabilizar é um
verbo muito interessante que significa
reunir as condições para alcançar um
objetivo criar uma via uma ponte
eu gosto muito de pensar numa imagem que
a do barco aprender pode ser como uma
expedição a gente pode imaginar o
processo de aprendizado como se a gente
tivesse um território ea gente quiser
chegar no ponto b num terreno
desconhecido e nesse meio tem um oceano
que a gente precisa atravessar como que
a gente faz isso o primeiro passo
a gente reúne uma tripulação e aí para
ilustrar esses passos eu queria fazer
uma pergunta pra vocês é o seguinte quem
é que gostaria de começar a aprender a
investigar o tema inovação na educação
levanta a mão pra mim falou bastante
gente
obrigado
essa é a população ela já está montado
se a gente tivesse falando de um caso lá
fora
basta um chamado de uma pessoa pode ser
um post no facebook pode ser um post no
blog pode ser falar com os amigos no
piauí
pode ser aqui no tek reúne a tripulação
para que a gente consiga fazer essa
expedição chegar no terreno desconhecido
o segundo passo é a gente se perguntar
como tripulação como grupo como
comunidade como que a gente vai aprender
isso que fascina gente e aí tem n formas
aqui estão algumas por exemplo a gente
pode entrevistar pessoas que estão
interessadas em inovação educação tem um
monte de gente que sabe muito sobre isso
mas pode entrevistá-las a gente pode
fazer workshops
a gente pode propor a gente mesmo
desafios assistir vídeos fazer projetos
coletivos e
qualquer outra coisa que a nossa cabeça
pra imaginar o terceiro passo é a gente
se perguntar também como que a gente
pode sustentar nosso percurso e aí eu
queria mostrar dois caminhos existem
vários também a primeira forma a gente
sem usar dinheiro a gente consegue
sustentar a gente pode fazer parcerias
por exemplo tem um grupo é lá em são
paulo que a comunidade novas economias é
justamente isso a gente reúne uma
tripulação pra estudar profundamente o
tema novas economias
esse grupo está começando agora ea gente
conseguiu fechar uma parceria com o
espaço
os nossos encontros são mensais de final
de semana
e esse espaço a gente trocou por alguns
serviços que a gente podia oferecer pra
eles e os nossos encontros acontecem
sempre lá
uma outra possibilidade é usar o recurso
financeiro
e aí eu dou o exemplo de plataformas de
financiamento coletivo recorrente que
agora já estão surgindo vários no brasil
por exemplo catar as assinaturas que a
gente está usando nesse grupo de novas
economias e o apoia essa é uma forma da
gente sustentar colaborativamente esse
esforço de aprender juntos e o
financiamento coletivo é como se fosse a
assinar uma revista mensal que a gente
pode gerar valor para as pessoas
a partir disso por fim esse grupo também
se pergunta o que a gente vai entregar
pro mundo o conhecimento que a gente vai
compartilhar isso também pode assumir
várias formas
pode ser um mapeamento pode ser uma
startup pode ser um documentário um
livro como eu fiz mas é o grupo que vai
decidir qual é o formato com
viabilização é isso é tão simples quanto
esses quatro passos
então a gente formar uma comunidade de
aprendizagem que intencionalmente chega
nesse terreno desconhecido que se propôs
a chegar
eu acredito que por meio desses
princípios e por meio desses espaços
a gente vai conseguir manter essa chama
da curiosidade acesa
mesmo se a gente tiver igual esse
palitinho aí todo quebrado por conta de
imposições avaliações provas pressões do
sistema educacional tradicional
a gente vai conseguir manter a chama da
curiosidade aberta e pulsando dentro da
gente é isso que eu desejo para cada um
de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]